proposition de loi que nous avons
adoptée jeudi
en fait elle crée un crime autonome
c'est une nouvelle infraction qui
qualifie les pénétrations sexuelles sur
les jeunes mineurs de 13 ans
c'est à dire les enfants de moins de 13
ans n'auront plus à prouver qu'ils
étaient consentants puisque par
définition ils seront contraints
c'est à dire que l'auteur de cette
infraction sera impuni comme si c'était
un viol de 20 ans de prison
donc moi j'ai fait a ajouté un article
additionnel disons que la contrainte
serait un élément pour un enfant de 13 à
15 ans qui seraient victimes qui
pourraient être déduit donc deux
sondages moins de 15 ans et de son
absence de maturité sexuelle
écoutez nous nous sommes depuis le début
de l'existence de ce débat pour 15 ans
pour moi dans les affaires que je traite
depuis 20 ans au quotidien avec les
rencontres avec des victimes
je trouve qu en deçà de 15 ans il il ne
peut pas y avoir discussion sur le
consentement d'une mine art ou d'un
mineur nous nous sommes pour 15 ans même
si j'apprécie et je comprends ce que dit
madame mercier pour moi c'est 15 ans
pour moi si on était si on ne venait pas
de si loin que c'est le cas en france
on aurait pu dire la majorité est à 18
ans on peut pas conduire ni boire de
l'alcool ni beauté avant 18 ans avant 18
ans on ne peut pas non plus avoir une
relation sexuelle avec une avec une
mineure par par essence
née en moi je trouve que l'époque a
changé je trouve que dans les cas
d'inceste et dans les cas d'enfants
mineurs en situation d'handicap
effectivement il faudrait retenir 18 ans
à mon avis pour un pays comme la france
on peut se dire que 15 ans est un bon
âge et que s'ils ont demandé 16 ans 17
ans 18 ans ça passerait pas ça passerait
pas parce qu'on est en france
la france est un pays qui a eu et pour
moi en français une culture de viol pour
moi en france il y a eu une tolérance
depuis des décennies vis-à-vis de des
relations sexuelles adultes enfants le
pour moi une fillette de 13 ans et un
jour est aussi vulnérable qu'une de 13
ans moins un jour et idem pour les 15
ans donc j'avais proposé au sénat un
amendement qui avait été adopté pour
protéger les mineurs de moins de 18 ans
quand vous avez une gamine de 17 ans et
demi qui est violée sous une tente lors
d'un concert ce n'est absolument pas
acceptable
de la même façon que le viol est
toujours un crime et quel que soit l'âge
puisque par définition le viol
impliquant non consentement donc les
effets d'âge pour moi sont un peu gênant
puisqu'il pourrait amener à moins bien
protégé celui qui est juste au dessus
voilà pourquoi le juge doit déterminer
cette fameuse maturité sexuelle qui
différente de la maturation sexuelle
on a le droit à pas tout à fait 18 ans
ne pas être mature sexuellement et de
l'être un peu plus sa saison ça dépend
des enfants
[Musique]
l'éducation passe vraiment par
l'importance de la prévention un petit
enfant qui saura tout jeune que personne
n'a le droit de le toucher
eh bien il dira non des tout petits et
c'est cette éducation qu'il faut
absolument accentuée dans les écoles
c'était du cassiot est absolument
absolument déterminante pour l'avenir de
nos enfants de nos jeunes de nos petits
citoyens
l'éducation c'est capital c'est de
changement des mentalités
cebu changement de cet abus de position
dominante je pense que c'est ce qu'avait
dit rossi auraient marre quand elle
parle de viol dans la culture française
c'est cette culture de la position
dominante qu'on peut retrouver et contre
laquelle nous devons lutter pour
protéger tous nos enfants nos mineurs
même nos mineurs de moins de 18 ans la
france a des lois qui protègent les
enfants mais les tribunaux qui sont des
qui serait dédié à l'enfant c'est cela
que nous demandons depuis longtemps un
peu sur le modèle de l'espagne avec des
tribunaux dédié avec des enquêteurs
dédiés avec des magistrats fort mais le
souci c'est qu'il n'y a pas de moyens
suffisants
ce qui fait que souvent les magistrats y
pour aix yona lice pour éviter les
assises et cetera pour éviter le
d'engorger d'accumuler d'espèces qui
n'est pas tolérant et toute la chaîne
humaine qui doit prendre des décisions
pour la protection des mineurs ou d'une
mineure doit avoir reçu une formation au
manque des personnes qui ont qui ont
reçu des formations
ça c'est une chose et effectivement
après on peut aussi parler d'autres
principes comme la prescription
je pense que demander l'
imprescriptibilité ça serait peut-être
impossible en france on l'a obtenue dans
d'autres pays mais de nouveau en france
je mets un bémol dans tous mes dans tous
mes espoirs parce que la france est un
pays très particulier dans le domaine de
la relation sexuelle à dix huit enfants
c'est la loi qui dicte la culture d'un
pays
et si on veut casser avec cette image de
la france étant un pays où il ya une
culture de viol il faut commencer par là
il faut commencer par des lois claires
et vraiment protecteur des enfants
on peut pas dire les choses et pas les
faire sur le terrain
ça ferait encore plus pâle